[Music]  i made it  [Music]  can you just tell me a little story  okay my story's called pinky tinkerbank  saves the stars  pinky tinkerbank and her mommy were best  friends  morning  they went to the park together  played dress-up together  then one day pinkie's mommy got sad  [Music]  every night before bed pinkie would wish  on a star  hello miss davis can you tell me what  happened  a little by little  julie wait it's okay  it's okay  the stars were starting to disappear  from the sky  there was nothing left for her to wish  upon  what if you stop loving me i'm never  gonna stop loving you  you can do this too you can  i was walking through a world that was  black and white  now i'm just starting to see color again  [Music]  sometimes the stars are blocked by the  clouds  [Music]  but even if you don't see them  they're always there  [Music]  you